hello I'm going to talk to you today
about the carbon cycle so what the
carbon cycle is is basically carbon is
never created or destroyed on earth it's
just moved from one place to another so
what the carbon cycle shows is how
carbon moves throughout different stores
and different places around the earth so
lots of people get overwhelmed and
remembering the carbon cycle so the best
way to do it is just step by step okay
so again with I'm thinking about the
carbon dioxide that's in the atmosphere
so carbon exists some carbon exists in a
gaseous form as carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere
now there's an only one thing that
removes carbon dioxide from the air in a
carbon cycle and that is through a
process of photosynthesis by plants so
here I have my plant which is photo
synthesizing remember this is the
process that plants do they need carbon
dioxide and water to make their own
glucose so the carbon has been taken out
of the air into or out the atmosphere
into the plants okay so again we're just
taking it step by step so we're thinking
what could happen to this plant now I
know you've drawn a tree here but this
could represent any plant so this plant
could get eaten by an animal so here is
my beautiful sheep okay there it is so
we can see so by eating we have passed
that carbon from the plant into the
animal okay so next up we're going to
think about what all living things do
one of the things that all living things
do is they respire now what respiration
is remember is the way that we get
energy from our food so it's a way of
releasing energy from glucose and one of
the one of the waste products of
respiration is carbon dioxide so as
animals and plants respire they release
carbon dioxide
now this is a stage a lot of people
forget a lot of people forget that
plants respire because they think they
only take in carbon dioxide they take in
much more carbon dioxide in
photosynthesis than they release in
respiration we've got to remember they
still do release some carbon dioxide
during respiration okay so what we're
going to think of now is it's quite sad
but some of these animals and plants
well all of them virtually will die and
they will be they will decay okay so as
they're broken down by microorganisms by
bacteria in the search light again
carbon dioxide is released into the
atmosphere okay so um we can see there's
lots of things returning comes the
carbon dioxide to the atmosphere and
what can also happen to these sheep and
these plants is if they're in the right
conditions over millions of years of
heat and pressure they can actually be
turned into fossil fuels such as coal
oil and natural gas so again that carbon
has been moved from these planks and
animals into the fossil fuels the carbon
is now stored here now what do we do
with fossil fuels well humans burn them
so we burn them to release loads and
loads of energy loads of chemical energy
which is locked up inside them so as we
burn them the scientific name for
burning remember is combustion as we
burn them the carbon dioxide is released
from the fossil fuels and returned to
the atmosphere so that is this that
essentially is the carbon cycle the way
to remember it is just work one step at
a time think about the different
potential fates of our plants and of our
animal remember that the only arrow
coming out of the attitude the only
thing that's taking carbon upside out of
the atmosphere is plants
photosynthesizing
and apart from that just practice
practice practice thank you very much